the Iranian government is not happy to
be singled out by President trumpet is
accusing the u.s. of Iran a phobia and
selling weapons to quote dangerous
terrorists as if Palmer is in the
Iranian capital of Tehran where the new
American rhetoric is bringing back old
memories Elizabeth good morning good
morning Iranians are waking up this
morning to find themselves squarely back
in the firing line of the White House
the view from here is that Donald Trump
came to Saudi Arabia mainly as a sales
rep for American arms manufacturers one
headline referring to this moment in the
visit said for a hundred billion dollars
Trump dances to the Saudi tune on Friday
Iranians re-elected reformist president
Hassan rouhani over his hardline
opponent and over the weekend jubilant
young voters celebrated in the streets
looking forward to fresh cooperation and
expanded business ties with the West and
the US but one short paragraph in
president Trump speech dashed their
hopes Iran funds arms and trains
terrorists militias and other extremist
groups that spread destruction and chaos
across the region he went on to say Iran
should be isolated in response iran's
Foreign Minister Javad Zarif who worked
with American negotiators to sign the
nuclear deal recalled the Saudi role in
9/11 and then tweeted Iran fresh from
real elections attacked by the president
in that bastion of democracy and
moderation a mocking reference to Saudis
absolute monarchy there is one faction
inside Iran's complex power structure
that may be celebrating today the
hardliners and the military including
Iran's powerful Revolutionary Guard
pulser ties with the west challenge
their influence in control whereas an
America that's not only allied with
Iran's Arab enemies but is arming them
too fits perfectly with their narrative
that Iran has to be aggressive to do
since President Trump joined the war of
words that rages constantly in this
region but Iranian czar now waiting to
see whether he actually backs it up
with the muscle of new anti Iranian
policy charlie this is the Elizabeth
Palmer in Tehran thanks